at the end of the mandalorians chapter
12
the heiress bocatan crees teased the
impending appearance of a long-awaited
character
guiding mando to a meet-up with ahsoka
tano in the fifth episode of the season
chapter 13 the jedi
ahsoka finally showed up
okatan sent me rosario dawson brought
ahsoka to life in the episode
capably bringing the beloved character
to live action for the first time
having ahsoka joined the live-action
side of the star wars universe was every
bit as amazing as fans hoped it would be
with the former jedi padawan revealing
tomando the truth about baby yoda
and the pair storming the city of
caledon on corvus
one of the most intriguing elements of
ahsoka's appearance in the mandalorian
of which there are many
comes about during her standoff with the
imperial magistrate morgan ellsbeth
who offered mando a best scar spear in
exchange for killing ahsoka
kill the jedi and it's yours
as the two prepare to duke it out ahsoka
brandishes
two white lightsabers seeing a white
lightsaber anywhere in the star wars
galaxy is unique
and would certainly raise some questions
but having a pair of them pop up in the
mandalorian has sparked up a lot of
conversation amongst the series fans
let's take a dive into star wars lore
and ahsoka's backstory to break down
what her white sabers really mean
when she was first introduced in star
wars the clone wars the former jedi had
green lightsabers but
she's been on a significant journey
since then ahsoka began
as the apprentice of anakin skywalker
the powerful jedi knight whose story
turns grim when he betrays
everything he once stood for to become
the insidious darth vader
there's a lot that happens between the
two as anakin grows
increasingly toward the dark side and
ahsoka becomes alienated from the jedi
path
in the fifth season of the clone wars
ahsoka winds up framed for a deadly
explosion at the jedi temple
causing her to leave the jedi order
though she's later exonerated
at the end of the clone wars vader picks
up one of the blue lightsabers he gifted
to ahsoka amongst the remains of the
crashed star destroyer and lights it up
before walking
away believing that ahsoka is dead of
course
she's still alive and when ahsoka
appears in star wars rebels
she wields different sabers the same
white ones
seen in the mandalorian ahsoka is unique
in the star wars universe because while
she no longer
identifies as a jedi she also hasn't
turned to the dark side
as clone wars executive producer and
mandalorian director dave filoni
previously explained
ahsoka's white lightsabers are meant to
show that she is neither a jedi nor a
sith
revenge is not the jedi way
i am no jedi while there's a clear
element of metaphor at play with
ahsoka's lightsabers
there's also a definitive reason why her
twin weapons are white
in ik johnston's 2016 novel ahsoka
the author fills in the gap between the
clone wars and rebels
prior to reappearing in rebels ahsoka
defeats an inquisitor and takes his
lightsaber crystals
because he is a sith his crystals were
corrupted but ahsoka heals them and
realigns them with force
this turns them white a symbol not only
of their restored purity
but also of ahsoka leaving the order
behind to fight for good in her own way
while the mandalorian marked her first
live-action appearance in the franchise
ahsoka has been hugely influential in
the world of star wars for years
not only is she the first major female
jedi audiences
spent time with on screen she's also a
fan favorite whose decision to turn her
back on the order
but not on fighting against evil makes
her a uniquely complex trailblazer
within the world of the franchise
in an april 2020 interview with vanity
fair dave filoni explained the
significance of ahsoka's choice to
separate from the order
saying she's not a jedi not because she
couldn't be but because she chose a
different path
ahsoka choosing to leave the jedi order
was one of the most powerful moments of
the clone wars series
and i think is one of the most important
stories in all of star wars
she left the order but she didn't stop
helping people she went her own way
and helped take down the empire so i
wouldn't call her a jedi or a padawan
she's a hero check out one of our newest
videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite star wars legends are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one